DAGEN McDOWELL.
"THE FIVE"."
AT LAST NIGHTS TOWN HALL,
DONALD TRUMP WAS ASKED ABOUT THE
MEDIA.
I BET HE LIKES THAT QUESTION.
I’M NOT SURE, BUT I THINK HE
LIKED THAT QUESTION.
>> I THINK GUY LIKE THAT
QUESTION.
I’M NOT SURE BUT I THINK I LIKE
THAT QUESTION.
I APPRECIATE IT.
I APPRECIATE THE PRAYERS VERY
MUCH.
I AM GREETED WITH A HOSTILE
PRESS THE LIKES OF WHICH NO
PRESIDENT HAS EVER SEEN.
THE CLOSEST WOULD BE THAT
GENTLEMAN RIGHT UP THERE, THEY
ALWAYS SAID LINCOLN, NOBODY GOT
TREATED WORSE THAN LINCOLN.
I BELIEVE I AM TREATED WORSE.
I FEEL THAT IF I WAS KIND TO
THEM, I WOULD BE WALKED OFF THE
STAGE.
THEY COME AT YOU WITH THE MOST
HORRIBLE, HORRENDOUS, BIASED
QUESTIONS.
YOU SEE IT.
94 95% OF THE PRESSES HOSTILE.
>> Greg: I KNOW, I KNOW.
LINCOLN’S RUN DIDN’T END WELL
BUT TRUMP WAS REFERRING TO
ASSAULTS BY THE MEDIA, NOT BY
DISGRUNTLED ACTORS, ALTHOUGH
THEY ARE EASILY CONFUSED.
THE DANGER WITH ASKING TRUMP
ABOUT THE PRIZES THAT IT CREATES
A NEVER ENDING MEDIA SPIRAL, THE
MEDIA ATTACKS TRUMP.
TRUMP FIGHTS BACK, THE MEDIA
RESPONDS ANGRILY.
SO TRUMP RIPS THEM AGAIN WHICH
THEY COVER AGAIN LIKE IT’S
D-DAY.
MEANWHILE WE ALL ARE MEMBER WHO
HELPED ELECT TRUMP, THE MEDIA.
SOME OF TODAY’S LOUDEST TRUMP
HATERS FOUND ALL OVER HIM DURING
ELECTION SEASON.
I WOULD RATHER HIM GENERAL ROOMS
WITH INSULTS AND STINGY WITH
BLOOD AND TREASURE.
IN THE HOLLYWOOD REPORTER THE
PRESS LAMENTS HOW EXHAUSTED THEY
ARE COVERING TRUMP.
IT’S HECTIC PACE THEY SAY.
SO WOULD THEY PREFER SOMEONE
SLOW AND SLEEPY WHO JUST BOMBS?
THEN THEY ALSO COMPLAINED ABOUT
HAVING TO COVER IMPEACHMENT
WHICH WAS THEIR OWN OBSESSION
THE LETTER VIRUS SNEAK UP ON US.
EXTEND THE CLUELESSNESS OVER
DECADES AND YOU WONDER HOW MUCH
STUFF THEY REALLY MISSED.
SO NOW THEY POINT FOR NORMALCY
THEY CAN SLOW DOWN, TAKE SELFIES
AGAIN, WHICH LEAVES THEM WITH
JOE.
HE’S PERFECT.
OLD, SLOW, LOVES A GOOD NAP.
WON’T BREAK A SWEAT COVERING
HIM.
PLUS HE JUST PROMISED TODAY THAT
AS PRESIDENT, THERE WILL BE NO
BULLYING OF THE MEDIA.
WHAT A TELLING DEAL.
GIVEN THAT HE’S BEING DOGGED BY
A SEX SCANDAL.
MEDIA, WHAT DO YOU THINK?
JOE SAID IF YOU ELECT HIM IT ALL
GOES BACK TO SLEEP, RETURNED A
MAGNIFICENT HIBERNATION.
JOE WILL BE THE LAPDOG THAT
WON’T BITE.
HE WILL JUST SNIFF.
JESSE, LET’S FACE IT.
IF YOU’RE GOING TO INTERVIEW
DONALD TRUMP IN FRONT OF THE
GIANT ABE LINCOLN, YOU THINK
HE’S NOT GOING TO COMPARE AND
CONTRAST?
IT’S KIND OF A SET UP, DON’T YOU
THINK?
>> Jesse: YES.
ABE WILL COME UP IN THAT
CONVERSATION.
YOU CAN GUARANTEE.
CAN YOU IMAGINE, GREG, THE MEDIA
AND HOW THEY SOUND -- HOW THEY
WOULD SOUND IF BARACK OBAMA OUR
PRESIDENT DURING THE PANDEMIC.
IT WOULD GO SOMETHING LIKE THIS,
BARACK OBAMA PUTTING POLITICS
ASIDE AND SACRIFICING, THE KEY
TO A SUCCESSFUL REELECTION, SHUT
DOWN THE ECONOMY.
IN ORDER TO SAVE LIVES.
HIS BOLD, EARLY AND SCIENTIFIC
BASED ACTION SHUTDOWN FLIGHTS
FROM CHINA WHILE HIS POLITICAL
OPPONENTS IMPEACHED HIM.
THEN HE RALLIED BOTH PARTIES
TOGETHER TO PASS ENORMOUS RELIEF
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND AT A
VERY GOOD MOMENTS, RALLIED THE
WORLD AROUND CHINA WHILE HIS
MAIN POLITICAL OPPONENTS STATED
IN THE BASEMENT AROUND THE DARK
CLOUD OF VERY CREDIBLE SEXUAL
ASSAULT ALLEGATIONS.
THAT’S WHAT IT WOULD SOUND LIKE.
NOW, I KNOW THE PRESIDENT IS NOT
GOING TO GET GREAT COVERAGE LIKE
THAT BUT THE PRESIDENT JUST
WANTS FAIR COVERAGE, BECAUSE HE
NEVER GOT CREDIT FOR WINNING THE
ELECTION.
THEY SAID RUSSIA CHEATED.
HE NEVER GOT CREDIT FOR THE
ECONOMY.
THEY SAID IT WAS BARACK OBAMA’S.
HE’S NOT GETTING CREDIT FOR
ANYTHING.
FOR VENTILATORS, FOR FLATTENING
THE CURVE, FOR THE TRAVEL BAN.
YOU KNOW WHEN THEY FIND A
VACCINE OR DO ANYTHING POSITIVE
THEY’RE NOT GOING TO GIVE MANY
CREDIT.
THIS IS WHAT HE WANTS, TO BE
TREATED FAIRLY.
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW, THEY ARE
BLAMING HIM FOR EVERYTHING AND
PRAISING CHINA.
I’M OLD ENOUGH TO REMEMBER WHEN
BARACK OBAMA COMPARED HIMSELF
NOT ONLY TO LINCOLN BUT TO FDR,
REAGAN, AND JFK.
THE MEDIA DIDN’T SAY SQUAT.
THEY NODDED IN AGREEMENT.
BUT DONALD TRUMP COMPARES
HIMSELF TO LINCOLN AND THEY ACT
LIKE HE DOESN’T EVEN KNOW THAT
HE WAS SHOT.
THAT’S HOW BAD IT IS.
HERE’S THE LAST POINT ABOUT HOW
BIASED THEY ARE.
WHEN THEY EVEN TALK ABOUT THE
COMPARISON BETWEEN LINCOLN AND
TRUMP, THE MEDIA CAN’T EVEN
REPORT THAT LINCOLN WAS A
REPUBLICAN.
THEY HATE TO ADMIT THAT, SO THEY
JUST DON’T ADMIT IT.
>> Greg: ONLY COMPARE MYSELF
TO WILLIAM HENRY HARRISON
BECAUSE NO ONE EVER DOES.
YOU’VE GOT TO ADMIT IT’S KIND OF
WEIRD THAT TODAY BIDEN SAYS IF
YOU ELECT ME, IF YOU ELECT ME I
WILL PLAY NICE, I’M NOT GOING TO
BULLY YOU.
HE’S BASICALLY SAYING THE SEX
SCANDAL STUFF, I AM MIND-READING
HERE, I COULD BE WRONG, BUT
DON’T YOU FIND THE TIMING A BIT
ODD?
>> Juan: NO.
IN FACT, YOU KNOW, YESTERDAY
THAT QUESTION THAT YOU CITED,
GREG, CAME FROM SOMEONE WHO
SEEMS TO BE A TRUMP FAN.
WHAT SHE SAID IN THE QUESTION
WAS BASICALLY MR. PRESIDENT, WHY
ARE YOU ALWAYS BOASTING?
WHY ARE YOU ALWAYS BULLYING?
WHY ARE YOU ALWAYS BAD MOUTHING
PEOPLE?
MAYBE YOU SHOULD TRY A DIFFERENT
TACK.
THAT’S WHERE THE QUESTION CAME
FROM.
I JUST THINK EVEN IF THE
PRESIDENT WANTS TO COMPARE
HIMSELF TO LINCOLN, OBVIOUSLY BY
HIS DEMISE, A DIFFERENT OUTCOME
IN TERMS OF BAD TREATMENT, BUT
HISTORICALLY IF YOU THINK ABOUT
THE FOUNDING OF THE COUNTRY,
JEFFERSON GOING AFTER ADAMS WHEN
THERE WAS ONLY A PARTISAN PRESS
AND THEY WOULD PLANT STORIES
ABOUT EACH OTHER, THAT WAS
PRETTY NASTY.
RICHARD NIXON GOT OUT AND SAID
YOU WON’T HAVE ME TO KICK AROUND
ANYMORE.
TALK TO LYNDON JOHNSON ABOUT BAD
PRESS IN VIETNAM.
SO TO ME, I JUST DON’T GET IT.
I WANT TO MAKE TWO OTHER QUICK
POINTS, GREG.
THE FIRST ONE IS ON THE
TIMELINE, YOU KNOW, IT SEEMS TO
ME THAT WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP
TALKS ABOUT HOW, YOU KNOW, HE
ACTED QUICKLY.
I DON’T THINK ANYBODY THINKS HE
BUT THEN HE SAYS NANCY PELOSI
WAS DANCING AROUND AS IF
NANCY PELOSI GETS THE
PRESIDENTIAL DAILY BRIEFING.
ACCORDING TO ALL THE REPORTS,
THIS THING WAS WARNING HIM AND
HIM ALONE AS PRESIDENT ABOUT THE
DAMAGE THAT COULD BE DONE ABOUT
THE CORONAVIRUS.
HE WAS THE ONE WHO WAS SLOW TO
ACT, NOT NANCY PELOSI, WHO
DIDN’T HAVE THAT INFORMATION.
SO I THINK HE DRAWS THESE
COMPARISONS AND AGAIN, IT JUST
SEEMS TO ME LIKE HE’S MAKING
EXCUSES WAY UP FRONT AND
UNNECESSARILY.
ONE OTHER THING THAT I WOULD
SAY, THE BUSINESS ABOUT YEAH, I
THINK THERE MAY BE MORE DEATHS
COMING.
WHY NOT HYDROCHLORIC LANE?
WE COULD TRY THAT STYLE.
I’M AMAZED THAT HE IS STILL
TALKING ABOUT THAT DRUG WHICH
HAS -- AS THE VA’S OWN STUDY
SAID DOESN’T HAVE ANY
EFFECTIVENESS IN TERMS OF
BATTLING THE COVID-19 VIRUS.
>> Greg: HE WENT OFF ON A LOT
OF TANGENTS.
EVERYBODY CAN POINT FINGERS.
I THOUGHT WE ALREADY WENT
THROUGH THIS.
IT’S ABOUT CORRECTING YOUR
MISTAKES.
TRUMP ACTED QUICKLY AFTER
PRESENTING AN OPTIMISTIC
PERSPECTIVE ANY OFTEN CHANGES
HIS PERSPECTIVE WHEN HE GETS
MEDICAL INFORMATION.
SO EVERYTHING HE DID WAS BASED
ON MEDICAL INFORMATION.
THE HYDROXY STUDY HAD ALREADY
COME UNDER HEAVY SCRUTINY
SCRUTINY BECAUSE IT WAS DONE
WITH SERIOUSLY OLD PEOPLE WHO
ARE ALREADY AT DEATHS DOOR THEY
WERE COMPARING IT TO PEOPLE WHO
ARE LESS ILL AND BY THE WAY, IF
YOU TALK TO DOCTORS, THEY ARE
STILL PRETTY STRONG ON THIS
STUFF.
I FIND IT WEIRD, DAGEN, THAT
WHEN THE PRESS COMPLAINTS ABOUT
CHROME, IT’S ALMOST ALWAYS
PSYCHOLOGICAL, NOT PHYSICAL.
THEY ARE NOT SAYING OH, MY GOD
HE’S INVADING COUNTRIES AND
CUTTING PROGRAMS FOR THE POOR,
BECAUSE HE’S NOT.
THEY COMPLAIN IT’S PSYCHOLOGICAL
THAT THEY CAN ENDURE IT BECAUSE
HE’S JUST TOO MUCH FOR US TO
HANDLE.
>> Dagen: BECAUSE THEY ARE
LAZY.
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO AVOID ANY
KIND OF REAL RESEARCH,
REPORTING, MANY OF THEM, NOT ALL
OF THEM.
ANY REAL ANALYTICAL THINKING.
THINK ABOUT HOW EASY THEIR JOB
HAS BEEN OVER THE LAST FOUR
YEARS, WHATEVER THE PRESIDENT
SAYS, WHATEVER THE PRESIDENT
DOES IN TERMS OF POLICY, YOU
JUST SAY "IT’S AN ATTACK ON"
FILLING THE BLANK.
HEALTH, SNEER, ROLL YOUR EYES
AND PULL A NASTY ADJECTIVE OR
NOUN OUT OF YOUR ARMPIT TO
INSULT HIM.
MEANWHILE, WHAT HAVE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE LEARNED FROM ALL
OF THIS REPORTING?
THEY’VE BEEN THE CRAP-QUEDUCT
FOR THE PRESS.
AS FOR JOURNALISM, I CAN’T SEE
IT ON TV.
IN TERMS OF WHAT THEY SERVE UP,
IT IS CREAMED CHIPPED BEEF ON
TOAST.
>> Greg: ONE OF MY FAVORITE
BREAKFAST TREATS.
I WANT TO GO BACK TO WHAT JOE
SAID ABOUT THE PROMISE THAT HE
WOULDN’T BULLY THE MEDIA.
IT STRUCK ME AS SAD.
I DON’T WANT TO PUT WORDS IN
YOUR MOUTH BUT IT STRUCK U.S.
ADD, DIDN’T IT?
>> Dana: I REMEMBER
HILLARY CLINTON, IF YOU ASK
HILLARY CLINTON ABOUT
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," SHE MIGHT
HATE "THE NEW YORK TIMES" MORE
THAN DONALD TRUMP DOES.
SHE TRULY BELIEVES THAT THAT
PAPER WAS ONE OF THE ONES,
REMEMBER THEY BROKE THE STORY
ABOUT THE CLINTON GLOBAL
INITIATIVE.
THEY RELENTLESSLY WENT AFTER THE
EMAIL STORY.
I THINK WHEREVER YOU SAID, WHEN
YOU’RE IN THE MIDDLE OF IT, YOU
THINK IT’S THE WORST THING THAT
ANYTHING IS EVER HAPPEN.
HISTORY HAS A LONG ARC.
IF I WERE PORTER, I WOULD
CONTINUE TO GET OUT OF
WASHINGTON, D.C., AND COVER THE
STORY ABOUT THE COUNTRY BECAUSE
IF YOU WANT TO TELL STORIES
ABOUT WHAT’S HAPPENING AND TRIED
TO AFFECT CHANGE IN WASHINGTON,
THAT’S THE BEST WAY TO DOING.
>> Greg: SUCH A GOOD PIECE OF